[Music]
shane is with us in cleveland ohio hi
shane welcome to the ramsey show
hey thank you both it's an honor to be
speaking with you you too what's up
hey so my question is this i guess a
little context uh my wife and i
discovered your program two years ago uh
which a lot of happened in the last two
years obviously very thankful for that
and we are we'll be in baby step seven a
year from today is our plan
and my question to you is
does it ever make sense to have more
than one financial advisor in your
corner
what would be the purpose
so we've been looking through the elps
we've been shopping around and we found
some really great people in our area and
they're just a few that we really like
and we're just curious if it makes sense
to maybe give a little bit of money one
and then a little bit of money to the
other and see who performs better is
does that just over complicating things
or does it make sense to do that i i try
to keep things as simple as possible
yeah
um
it's using the tool wrong
it's not up to them to perform it's up
to you to perform
it's up to them to teach you
and you make the decisions
and if both of them are teaching you and
they're giving you slightly different uh
teaching then you're just going to be
confused
so i would use one
but you don't want to you're not handing
them the money as a test and going okay
who wins the race
because they're not in the race you are
you see the difference
yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah and
so
um
you know i don't get two tax guys to run
my or tax people to run my uh tax
returns and see who wins
i need my taxes done right with the most
possible
uh money not going to the government the
least money going to the government
possible
and um you know so that that's the goal
that is legal and moral and
you know uh we just came through an
audit which is the first time i've
gotten that wonderful um
inspection of my body parts it's like
right yeah unbelievable and it came out
you know what i came out with
owing zero
wow that's how good we are because we're
fanatics about the integrity of doing it
properly right yeah we don't lie we
don't cut corners we don't cheat i hate
taxes i hate that the government takes
so much of my money but i'm gonna do it
exactly right so it's my job to make
sure that the stuff's filed right and i
use an an advisor a a professional in
that corner yeah i i just learned to
play golf i've been learning to play
golf i'm not any good in the last three
years
and one of the best pieces of advice i
got and everybody's got a freaking
opinion about golf i've never seen a
sport
with as much
diverse
stupid stuff in it i mean my god
and so but one of the the single best
piece of advice that goes don't get more
than one coach
because they'll just they'll make you
schizophrenic at your golf swing and you
know make you multiple personalities
with your golf swing whatever whatever
the phrase is it's a metaphor here but
um anyway so yeah i i so i got one guy
and i'm doing that one when i cease to
believe that he's moving me to the next
level then i'll get a different guy well
and that's what i heard here is
i like them i want to i want to prove i
want them to prove themselves to me and
if you don't trust the person yeah with
your retirement account that's teaching
you go to somebody else but the proving
needs to be did i learn something and am
i comfortable making these choices
because they showed me how to handle my
money right not because i handed it to
them and one of them does better than
the other and or they gave me some magic
dust package that was going to exhibit
that's returned right the financial
world is full of those people yes yep
that's exactly right that that's what
we're looking for so that's a really
good question
but yeah i use one
uh insurance professional
i use one
real estate professional
my son-in-law i use one uh
you know i i one golf coach
uh one uh
smartvestor pro oh that makes sense
because i'd sent you an email back just
asking if i could help you with your
golf swing and you never wrote back
i now understand it wasn't because of me
it's because i have played golf with
happy gilmore
you know the running you know the
running swing that gilmore has as he
runs at the ball with a driver i'm not
great this is john i'm not great i play
with john and john drove a 310 yard
green
on the 18th green he drove the green 310
yards the rest of the day he drove the
woods
with style hey man i mean i'm not great
i don't know how many balls he started
with i know how many he ended with
hey i borrowed some of these clubs
because i don't have my own and uh a
week later they're like hey man you owe
me like 20 bucks yeah you tore up my
club balls
used up their golf balls 20 bucks hey
man i sent golf balls all over where no
that was 200 bucks
20 bucks wouldn't bought those golf
balls i'm not great dave i'm not great
not great yeah that's well you brought
it up i you brought up coaching me so
i'm just saying
uh i'm not great but i'm
not happy gilmore you're better than me
uh i was afraid we're going to go into
that in the pond with that alligator and
get some others back
oh
thank you thank you adam sandler for the
memories